fait toujours en france militants et
organisations se sont rassemblés chiant
soutien en irak
manifestation à paris de la diaspora
algérienne la date coïncide avec le 59e
anniversaire de la fête de
l'indépendance en algérie après
l'interdiction de quatre marches en
raison d'un risque d'attentât à l'ordre
public la préfecture de paris avait
autorisé ce rassemblement cet après midi
défilé de la place de la république
direction la place de la nation
une victoire symbolique pour les
organisateurs côté manifestants un seul
mot d'ordre l'arrêt de la répression par
les autorités viennent pour nous c'est
important de rappeler qu'on a gagné que
le peuple algérien a battu une des
grandes un des grands collants qui
s'appelle la france et que
malheureusement petit à petit cette
indépendance a été grignotée et qui a
été remplacé par une dictature le
pouvoir au lieu de répondre aux
aspirations du peuple par l'application
de l'article c'est évident à savoir le
respect de la souveraineté populaire
il répond par l'article 87 à savoir
incriminés tout acte politique
les prisons l'algérie croupissent
d'innocents les richesses sont dilapidés
la souveraineté est compromise le
territoire est vendu
on est au protectorat de la france et
d'autres pays
le peuple algérien veut se réapproprier
son pays
toujours dans la revendication d'une
nouvelle algérie
démocratique réellement démocratique et
surtout la libération de tous les
détenus